o mundo está em transformação em todos
os santos se pode imaginar o mundo está
mudando as novas gerações que estão
chegando a minha tantas outras vêm
questionando vários velhos conceitos que
a gente insistia em manter do jeito que
sempre foram
nós estamos caminhando para um
questionamento muito profundo sobre
vários conceitos como futuro promissor
mercado de trabalho felicidade e
realização profissional e liberdade e eu
acho que em um meio tão transformador
então então em transformação que é o
mundo de hoje um dos grandes agentes
transformadores é a arte
pra mim a arte realmente sempre teve um
papel de ajudar na unidade a passar pela
vida
convenhamos não é fácil passar pela vida
é duro passar pela vida mas eu acho que
muito além do que ajudar a humanidade a
passar pela vida arte teve um papel e
ainda tem um papel fundamental isso todo
o santos já que a literatura dança
pintura jogue for ela consegue dizer o
que a própria humanidade não consegue
dizer sobre ela mesmo
ela consegue fazer com que a gente veja
coisas que nem gente sabia que existia
dentro da gente ela tem um papel
questionador um papel transformador de
fato eu me pergunto e pergunta vocês
nasf qualquer coisa porque em um
ambiente tão transformador em um mundo
tão em constante transformação a
literatura é permanecer imaculada porque
que ela permaneceria intacta porque eu
acredito que a literatura vem chamando a
minha vida desde muito cedo desde que
aprendi a escrever ea ler ela faz parte
da minha vida quando era criança o meu
pai é escritor wilson freire e minha mãe
ilustradora gosta de dizer que ela é
fundadora e os dois sempre me pegaram de
muita coisa então lembro de cenas muito
fortes da minha infância por exemplo
chegando em casa meu pai parceiro
antonio nova então chegava com a minha
malinha do colégio me sentar ao lado dos
dois estava na briga com sua rabeca com
seu violino e meu pai cheio de papel
fazer aquelas coisas eu queria me meter
na eape raia chato a gente pára e vai
terminar essa coisa aqui pra mim
a nova tela sério e eu começar a fazer
aquelas coisas e ao longo do tempo
comecei também a querer desenhar também
quanto à minha mãe era muito frustrante
porque ela fazia uma coisa muito bonita
com aquarela 166 vocês sabem os acordos
é muito de água então fazia uma papa com
papel e tinta que ficava horroroso mas
ela era a mãe dela estava lindo eu
acreditava e aí
ao longo do tempo depois vão explicar
melhor eu acho que comecei a confundir
uma coisa com a outra eu não sabia mais
o que era desenho que ela escrita porque
estava muito muito arraigados dentro de
mim e aí eu fui crescendo e escrevendo
porque desde muito cedo não fez só
acontece com vocês mas visita me visitam
todo me visita todas as madrugadas um
turbilhão de coisas eu sempre costumo me
comparar a figura de um vulcão um vulcão
por fora você pode até pensar que ele é
tranquilo mas por dentro é aquela
ebulição que está prestes a explodir o
tempo inteiro pra mim pra que ele não me
matar se não se focasse eu precisava
escrever desde pequenininho eu escrevi e
escrevia escrevia tudo isso naquela
naquele formato de poesia desenhada e eu
colocava tudo embaixo da cama tá que
ninguém visse
eu sempre fui muito egoísta nesse
sentido não queria que ninguém visse que
escrever eu tinha pavor de imaginar que
alguém pudesse ler o que eu tava devendo
ainda mais num país tão bom né o tudo
mas esse tipo também era muito difícil
quando ela tudo embaixo da cama
e aí comecei a crescer tudo mais me
tornei publicitária é que vários
caminhos pra tomar na carreira de
publicitário resolveu virar o que
redatora
aí eu fiquei arrasado e se gente tinha
tanta coisa pra fazer da vida vira
redatora publicitária vou escrever vou
ter que escrever mas pelo menos não
escrita que eu não precisava me expor
tanto estava vendendo o carro sabonete
roupa não precisa muito mais fácil
e aí entre um trabalho e outro da
agência
eu terminava o meu dia tenho que fazer a
minha frente também tem um jovem tem que
fazer a cabeça outro jovem de fazer a
cabeça do jovem nem só de fazer a cabeça
no final de meu trabalho estava cheio de
papel na minha mesa cheio e aí
obviamente eu pegava tudo jogado no lixo
porque não queria comprar papel ao longo
do tempo pessoal do meu trabalho começou
a perceber se o movimento estranho e eu
voltei do da minha casa nem para o novo
trabalho e estava todo meu lixo em cima
da minha mesa eu vi gente a faxineira tá
com raiva de mim é
eu fiz alguma coisa que ela não gostou
do que aconteceu me disseram não olha
isso é a gente que colocou seu lixo aqui
de volta porque a gente tá indignado que
está jogado no lixo se como as inserções
indignados com que direito vocês estão
bastante no meu lixo a lisa que mexeu
tanto no meu lixo
ela se você não pode jogar fora você
precisa salvar essas coisas você precisa
criar um blog
eu não sabia nem mexer na internet era
meu primeiro estágio então não sabia
como é que mexer nessas coisas
então depois de muita insistência e
resolveram me obrigaria a um blog porque
fazendo assim eu pararia de jogar tudo
no lixo
então decidi criar um golo naquele
momento que estava fazendo blog pra mim
disseram assim tá
como é que vai ser o nome dele e aí eu
voltei para a história dessa vez a minha
adolescência chegando a minha
adolescência lembrei de um professor de
teatro meu chamado silvio que estava
comigo no colégio e ele mostrou cheia
estava linda naquele dia linda então me
mostrou fez assim porém se você sabe
porque a lua cheia tão bonita se não o
fez porque ela é tão simples mas tão
simples que ela consegue refletir a luz
de outro maior do que ela
mesmo sendo só pó como é você e por
conta disso nossa noite não são escuras
aquilo foi tão forte pra mim que eu fiz
eu não quero escrever sobre isso eu
quero ser assim é assim que eu queria
ser
olha lua ela não entendendo o que por si
só mas festeja o belo de ser reflexo de
areia o feijão da escuridão
mesmo sendo apenas pó foi isso que eu
pensei vai se chamar por aí mas como é
que eu posso pensar melhor e eu lembrei
de outro episódio da minha adolescência
que foi quando assistir um filme chamado
caso de areia com fernanda torres
fernanda montenegro
nesse filme elas passa o filme inteiro e
volta é é cercada por dunas na areia ar
e embora numa casinha ele imaginando o
que tem lá na lua o que tem na lua o que
será que existe ali ela só respeitar
aquela lua no final a filha chega pra
mãe e desmaiou homem pisou na lua ea mãe
meu deus meu filho que tem lá areia e
aquilo pra mim também foi muito forte
sabe porquê porque a gente sempre fica
imaginando que estava na área está longe
no lugar a gente não pode alcançar e na
verdade é nominada nossa vida que a
gente encontra a poesia é a lei
cenário nacional possível na hora de
todos os dias no nosso lado e aí eu
acabei pensando tudo bem ele vai se
chamar então pode lua
esse é o nome que decide dar o meu blog
porque eu pensei ao longo do tempo que
eu precisava escrever e que gostava de
falar das coisas da vida quando ele
cabeça porque escolheu delicadeza eu
perceber que a vida como eu disse no
início é muito dura e difícil de passar
por ela nós encontramos nos deparamos ao
longo da vida com a fome com a dor com a
perda com a saudade
com tanta coisa difícil ea arte tem
também o papel de denunciar e de cantar
a beleza da feiúra da vida porque viveu
o sofrimento minha gente a gente vive na
altura da felicidade se a gente não foi
feliz na internet postado no facebook
todos os dias tem fracassado
vi o sofrimento é o momento mais
criativo a pessoa então eu fiquei
pensando por que eu não pega figuras com
uma vez que estava passando por um
viaduto e viu a menina sentada
balançando os terninhos e eu vi puxa o
nome dela vai ser licínia ela balançava
as pernas ela estava vendendo bala no
final e passavam os carros tão rápido
que eles fazem os o risco de luz embaixo
dela e eu fiquei imaginando se inicia se
jogasse naquele tipo de luz e começar a
flutuar pela cidade
viajando encontrando com todos os seus
sonhos de consumo das pessoas da cidade
e depois ela volta para o viaduto onde
os riscos são muito maiores
ou então quando estava no carnaval lá no
marco zero eu vi passar uma criatura do
meu lado que não sabem sabia bem o que
era ele estava ele andava diferença era
menor que os outros e ele tinha uma
corcunda todo relata
e eu vi que era um catador de latas que
ele andava mais baixo que todo mundo
cantando aquilo ali nem vi aquela figura
aquela sombra invisível passar muitas
pessoas eu fiz o corpo leve lata e esse
personagem ele tinha um mundo
maravilhoso mundo fantástico também
redor dele
a dureza deixa de existir a dor deixa de
existir a pobreza desses deixa de
existir não mas se a gente consegue
falar com delicadeza das coisas da vida
e das coisas da alma eu acredito que a
gente consegue falar de coração para
coração porque a mais dura das criaturas
do mundo tem alma
se você fala pra uma delas você toca
naquele lugar e é nesse lugar que
conseguiu
a única outra coisa que eu acho muito
importante é a simplicidade
gente eu acho que foi se o tempo em que
a literatura ela precisava ser
incompreensível que a boa literatura é
somente aquela que pouquíssimas pessoas
e atletas seriam capazes de entender e
apreciar a literatura pode ser simples
ela pode ser simples atenção simples é
diferente de fácil não é fácil ser
simples dá pra entender é muito difícil
chegar numa boa simplicidade é muito e
chegar na publicidade com profundidade
mas acredito muito nesse papel que a
arte pode ter de ser acessível para todo
mundo que a literatura pode ser
acessível para todo mundo por exemplo
por que que eu preciso apenas usar
palavras na poesia porque eu não posso
usar um objeto a tudo bem mas muita
gente já ilustra a poesia vão de
ilustração eu tô falando que o objeto
ele pode ser parte da poesia por exemplo
eu fui logo tomada por um desejo de
retomada isso é um alberto ou isso é uma
palavra eu sei lá porque a gente se
classificar
ela faz parte da poesia do mesmo jeito
então por que ela tem que seguir a
estrutura não é como a gente sabe que o
chamado longo do tempo ele não pode
tirar a vida gira o tempo todo e tal e
vejam bem imaginem isso no blog porque
comecei com a minha arte no blog depois
quando eu tinha um celular que eu não
quero falar trace foto quando eu
consegui um eu comecei a colocar aqui no
facebook e aquilo começou a se espalhar
muito rápido então para quê você tem
aqui e você consiga compreender a poesia
como essa você precisa lutar por ela no
meu time lá então chega de informação ou
você luta um pouco para conquistá la
você não vai conseguir entender isso é
muito legal ver que as pessoas fazem um
esforço de conquistar aquela poesia e aí
as coisas começaram a fugir do meu
controle
depois que comecei a colocar no facebook
tenha realmente a ferramenta muito mais
rápida as ruas começaram a se espalhar
se espalhar e de repente um blog de
poesia na internet começou a ter mais de
10 mil seguidores e aquilo para mim foi
um susto
dez mil seguidores consumindo poesia na
internet não seria ali um espaço para
compartilhamento de brincadeira que eu
gosto das bobagens volta à internet eu
acho muito legal mas só pra isso ou
então pra que a gente fala da vida um do
outro então a notícia da economia como
assim
uma literatura ainda mais para mim que
não tinha nome desse lugar e tudo mais
como assim
então pra mim foi a grande surpresa até
um belo dia que eu fiz uma poesia sobre
um palito de fósforo
esse planeta de fósforo é o seguinte
metade assim que todo inútil fósforo
eles disseram que na própria cabeça por
um segundo de fogo contou a quem pensa
assim eu acho não entendem nada do jogo
inútil é ser cantado em uma caixa até o
tempo fazer morrer sem saber o que a luz
sem saber o que é brilhar sem saber o
que é perder esse show ele teve 14 mil
compartilhamentos um dia só
eu estava no trabalho quase caí da
cadeira é o pessoal da agência mi5 assim
e ele perguntava por que as pessoas
estão desse jeito por causa da
importância de fósforo e minha resposta
foi muito simples na hora por causa de
um palito de fósforo é por causa da casa
de areia as pessoas sim estão buscando
dar significado é significante
as pessoas se estão precisando voltar a
essência das coisas a parar de procurar
o extraordinário longe na grama do
vizinho ou seja lá onde ela estiver lá
na lua e passar a olhar para as coisas
simples da vida a poesia está na própria
vida do que tem de mais belo que tem de
mais feio e eu acho que é por isso que o
foco chamou tanta atenção das pessoas e
cheguei à conclusão que a literatura
viva ela viva ela tem vontade própria
como assim
o seguinte eu acho que a literatura la
nación ela vem de dentro da gente ela
escolhe a plataforma que ela quer viver
que ela quer nascer eu acho a primeira
plataforma que ela escolhe o próprio
escritor
a poesia espólio correta essa primeira
plataforma da literatura depois se ela
vai para as páginas do facebook se ela
vai trabalhar no instagram se ela vai
para a internet traz páginas de um livro
pra ela pra qualquer outro lugar não
importa
e aí eu falo isso porque existe sim um
preconceito entre as pessoas
e pensar que a literatura que veio da
internet ela tem menos valor ou têm
menos peso do que ele estava duro que já
veio das prateleiras
e aí gente eu fico me perguntando
imaginem vocês figuras como cecília
meireles paulo leminski carlos drumond
de andrade essas pessoas que tivessem
acesso a ferramentas como a internet só
deles não utilizarem essa ferramenta
será que ele seria o mesmo escritor
por utilizar a ferramenta que pode
chegar todo mundo eu me pergunto
e aí veio o convite para fazer um livro
pegar todos os elementos da internet e
transformar nas páginas de um livro pela
editora intrínseca um grande desafio e
agora como é que a gente vai pegar algo
tangível leva pra casa e aí teve todo um
trabalho e tudo mais e esse livro
consegui me levar pra vários lugares que
a internet não conseguir levar gostar de
autógrafos é conseguir chegar perto de
pessoas que fazem que me contam
histórias como por exemplo estava na
tarde de autógrafos da mulher chegou pra
mim e disse para eu estava com síndrome
do pânico estava com depressão
fisioterapia fechou você imaginar 10 é
não deu certo
quando me encontrei com sua poesia eu
consegui voltar a trabalhar conseguir
voltar a ensinar sua professora de
literatura e quero falar sobre você
ou então escola pública que os alunos
não conseguiu ler de jeito nenhum é
parte da minha poesia começa a ler ou
então escola pública onde os alunos não
conseguiam declamar poesias porque eles
só falam libras ea minha cozinha eles
conseguem falar livros que conseguem ver
ea simplicidade chega perto deles e só
consigo o que consigo receber na tarde
de autógrafos
então gente eu fico pensando sabe é eu
acho que é uma grande evolução que a
literatura sempre conseguiu trazer é
mais silenciosa possível a grande
revolução silenciosa possível porque ela
vem caladinha gentileza lado a gente lá
em silêncio
ela vem e vai transformando e eu fico me
perguntando sabe se hoje no mundo de
hoje na transformação tão grande as
pessoas se estão buscando ainda o que
está no pequeno no pequeno as pessoas
ainda estão buscando que está no
essencial e aí eu acho que o deitado nas
redes das casas ou nas redes dos da
internet dos olhos de artifícios
altíssimo no mundo tão cheio de concreto
no mundo tão cheio de velas cidade não
está milagre tão cheio de informações
as informações passam a selphy espaço ea
poesia permanece na plataforma nova
trazida por uma geração nova que quer
trazer novidade para todos os âmbitos da
arte inclusive a literatura e que
maravilha porque é 2 velha literatura de
sempre adorando a uma roupa novo é isso
muito obrigada